Okay, just to remind you for everybody that's new, use the member site, you'll see any new announcements or anything changes or any updates.
I usually put announcements on the member site, anything you need to know.
For those of you that did not receive a glucose monitoring kit with your membership.
So that's something new.
I highly suggest to go pick one of these up.
I say down here understand this is not really appropriate for blood cancers and I really mean leukemia.
But the trauma yes, looking at your blood glucose can be helpful.
Certainly any solid tumor looking at your blood glucose can be helpful.
And you could download a chart to keep that monitor that could be helpful.
It's not the end all be off or anything with cancer, but it's just another way to monitor.
Also remember that all the courses are at your access.
If you've never read my book stop by the cancer, it's hard to read the cause.
You can download that free with the stop by writing cancer.
Course on the other ones that would be the most useful would probably be the autoimmune course, maybe the detox course.
You have just about everything in the frequency course in the member site.
Also remember to use the blog.
So if you think of a question that you wanted to answer to it right away, it might already have.
Am I already already written a blog post about it?
So look for that as well to try to save yourself some time.
Okay, so questions that came in.
And for those that are on the call, if you have questions, you can just chat them in along the way and we'll get to them.
We'll throw the questions that come in.
First question by legs, egg block or have to climb steps.
It does not stop me from walking and doing my exercises, my right leg.
As some neuropathy as a result of the chemotherapy I received back in 2020.
Could the aching indicate vascular problems? What do you recommend?
So, um, yes, so the leg aching could indicate intermittent claudication.
It could indicate some weakness of the fart.
So the questions that practitioner should ask is an examination should reveal does this person have swelling in their legs.
So if you if it's accompanied by swelling.
Then it's you think more of inability to drain so you that could be a function of the fart.
It could also be a function of the lymphatic drainage from the leg.
So, for instance, there could be a lot of problems. There could be a lot of causes of that.
And it could be let's say the person had, you know, if they're older and they have some sagging of some of the intestines putting pressure on the introverted cave.
At the Iliac veins, then that could cause some swelling and leg aches.
So, there's lots of possibilities. Some general nutritional possibilities could range from hydration, a loss of
acrylites. So, decrease in sodium, decrease in calcium, magnesium, your electrolytes.
So, especially during the summer days, if you're out and you're and you're burning a lot of your minerals.
And you're sweating, you can end up with some, you know, mild dehydration and decrease in electrolytes. And that could be an issue too.
Lots of, for that, you definitely want to think of a local practitioner to, to take a look at some of those possibilities that I discussed.
But you brought up the point of chemotherapy. So, chemotherapy can be an issue too because chemotherapy is highly toxic substance and can settle in your tissues.
And why do people end up with neuropathy from chemotherapy? Because of the blood flow, when that, when the chemotherapy is flowing through your blood and it gets out into the tissues,
it's harder to detoxify things from your extremities than it is from, you know, organs that are closer to the heart.
So, and chemotherapy is toxic to neurons so it can damage neurons. And more specifically, it's damaging the sensory receptors.
And the, what I call the large, accurate, large diameter, accurate neuro fibers, that's how and why a person ends up with neuropathy from chemotherapy.
There is a device called the rebuilder that we do sell in the store. It's a device that's an FDA approved device for neuropathy for either diabetic neuropathy or chemotherapy can do neuropathy.
And also with chemotherapy, you've got to think of doing some chelation work to try to pull that out if the person has bad neuropathy from the chemotherapy.
It's a hard one to deal with. You have, you have the benefit of having the ion pro wave at the right. That could be a real big help. I would say that should be your first thing that you should start with is doing more of the ion pro wave programs that you can look at.
The general ion pro wave programs with the right in the person had neuropathy unsafe and do the clear line detox. That's been the most helpful for chemotherapy induced neuropathy.
What is the best placement for my ball? Is it better to place it directly on my right breast, this person has breast cancer.
That was removed and radiated three years ago. I have been just making sure it was under the cover, but want to know if I should put the ball directly on my mind. So I have always said that it's better, the closer it is to you, the better it is.
If you're using the amplifier, you don't have to get it close to you at all. You could have put the ball underneath your bed if you're using the amplifier. So if you're not using the amplifier, I think the closer it is to you, the better.
Is it best to be right over the cancer? Yes, no, it's not necessary. It's personal as brain cancer. We have some people with brain cancer to put the ball right by their head.
I would find it difficult to sleep myself doing that. So that's not what we typically recommend.
The frequencies are strong enough, even if you don't have the amplifier for it to, you know, traverse your body, just by putting it near your body, and it doesn't have to be next to your brain, if you had brain cancer.
However, closest to the body part of the cancer is always best, except if you have the amplifier, you could go farther away.
But if you had no evidence of disease past breast cancer, you need to put it right up against the breast that was removed.
No, I'd say putting it next to your body is just fine.
Let's say you got to think, you know, wisely here. It's like, okay, if I had breast cancer, I had my breast removed, radiated three years ago, currently no evidence of disease using the right to keep me that way at this point.
Where would you most likely get recurrence of the disease? Yes, you could get it at the site at the chest wall, but likely you'd get recurrence of the disease.
In my lung, in my liver, in the bone with breast cancer. You wanted to go through your whole body, so I think you're fine if you just put it down, if you're tummy, and you're snuggling with the bone.
This strong and oral form of 5FU was used in chemo and radiotherapy, and also could be considered as a replacement for 5B 5FU has side effects, though. This includes hand foot syndrome.
Hand foot syndrome is a syndrome that's very common with people therapy patients, and it's because of what I just discussed a second ago, it's because these things are very toxic to neurons.
The hand foot syndrome, you can get these weird symptoms in your hands or your feet, in your extremities, to stuff specific to your hands and feet, but in your, in your further extremities.
And because it's a strong toxin, and so the question is, are you aware of natural options, perhaps, the leopathy to reduce the side effects of this oral chemo in general, or for hand foot syndrome.
So I think that your best option is to be doing the bioprolym, because you can do that on your hands, you can do that on your feet, and it will help pull that out.
The negative about doing that pro-wave is that that program can take like 45 minutes, and it's kind of a pain to do.
So that would be the downside, using some toxic keylators would be your next best thing.
But you do have to be aware of the seven phases of detoxification here, and make sure that you are.
Your body is ready to do phase zero of detoxification, which is using a key later to grab onto things to pull out of your body.
You also have to be aware that you can't really do any heavy keylators, if you have metal in your body.
So let's say you have a platinum plate from a fracture back when you were at high school, can't really do that or a nickel plate.
You can't do heavy keylators, if you still have mercury fillings, the silver fillings.
So if you have metal in your body that way, now if you have metal in your body like a pacemaker, you're fine, because it's encased in plaques and plastic and such.
So, but metal in your body that you could end up chelating could be a problem.
You don't have, don't fall in any of those categories, then think about doing some of your like chelation type therapies.
Just supporting glutathione pathways can be helpful as well. So using that liquid liposomal glutathione can be very beneficial.
Nutrients that will help stimulate glutathione alpha-ropaic acid and fly seed and some other things like that that help you through the failure recycling process can be helpful.
Also eating foods that support that pathway like onions, garlic can be helpful for that.
So glutathione as you're made intracellular detoxifier, but adding a key later helps grab onto it in the blood so it doesn't get to positive somewhere else.
So, if you don't have metal in your body, you feel like you've been addressing other detoxification pathways, which this person who asked this question has.
Think of things like our, if you're talking about a key later that I'm talking about a heavy key later is our product called what's in colors, but it's called key and clear.
So, if you do have metal in your body that is an issue, then you have to, you have to use key the clearest also cause we renamed it.
It's called phase zero.
And then we have another product that is designs for health, metal like synergy.
And that is really probably what that is, I think it is backward right now.
But that product is our private label, phase zero.
This is a little bit milder of a key later.
And that key look clear is key look clear is a stronger key later.
So, those are two products that you can think of that can be good.
Think about using binders in the gun too.
You do explain all those things in the same basic detox course to if you want to explore them.
Is prime protein, I grabbed the picture off the web here, a grass-fed beef isolate protein made with coconut milk powder, beet juice and stevia, a good protein choice.
Yeah, that's a good protein choice. If you have this, yes, absolutely.
You can use this product, that's just fine.
Remember, even this product, I think it's like 22 grams of protein, you really want to get how many grams of protein you want to really stimulate your immune system.
I don't know, well, the answer is you want to get an equal amount of grams protein.
As you wait in pounds.
So, if I weigh 200 pounds, you want to eat 200 grams of protein a day.
Doesn't make any sense to me taking that much protein powder.
I think about getting some chicken or good source beef and good salmon and you can certainly Google a document.
Maybe I could find one and put it up.
Maybe I did, I think I don't know if I did.
I'm a blog post that I describe this information, but so certainly don't want to be.
You know, taking it all in a protein powder, but this isn't great. I use it a protein powder is you can gain 20 grams, 25 grams protein by throwing that in your smoothie.
It's another good way to get stuff in.
I emailed you recently by my son or my lips went up the biggest dietary change for me was going on a ketogenic diet.
Not meat heavy, only 4 to 6 ounces of clean beef, lamb or chicken heavy and fats and leafy greens.
That's maybe that's why it's pronounced.
Other practitioner suspects allulose sweetener not metabolized.
She says it's probably fruit toast and that still messes me up.
Your thoughts on allulose. Allulose is a sugar substitute that is sugar alcohol.
Now, the benefit of sugar alcohol, it's thought that sugar alcohols don't increase your glucose levels.
And it's been proven that they don't increase most people's glucose levels, but some people do have a sensitivity to sugar alcohols and it can mess them up.
So that can be an issue, just like fruit toast.
Fruit toast is a common issue. Some people have an issue with fruit toast and it can spike their glucose levels.
Weird. So some people can eat, you know, can eat, you know, berries and they don't have a giant spike in glucose. Some people can have a glass of carrot juice and it doesn't spike their glucose.
Of course, I have one gal who she drank a half a glass of carrot juice where glucose will be way over 200 and she would just go get the shakes and all sorts of things.
She just had an issue with her ability to metabolize fruit toast and glucose from vegetables like that.
Some people can have issues like that that is that is kind of outside of the spectrum of what would be considered the majority of people. So just be aware of that.
The other thing she thought could be a factor is glyphosate.
She would like to test for it, says it affects salt variation cholesterol, all sulfate, all sulfates, redox enzymes, oxygen binding, deuterium metabolism, et cetera.
Or do you think that increase in consuming clean meat could be driving up lipids numbers that much over four months.
I don't think it's increased in the meats. I think it's increased in the fats that could be driving up your lipids.
But I do think all these other things have an effect too. So if my cholesterol goes up, is it because I'm eating more cholesterol? Well, usually it's not.
But if I'm eating a poor diet or if I'm eating a lot of fats that I'm having that could clog up my liver, that could increase my cholesterol.
So there's other things like your practitioner mentioned that clog up your liver and the most common is pesticides and herbicides and glyphosates fall into that category.
Now, getting a glyphosate test done is pretty simple. So we have that from Mosaic Labs. They have a glyphosate test. That's a nice little test.
And quite honestly, you know, we have run a lot of glyphosate tests said I have yet to see somebody come back with the normal limit of glyphosates.
So it's really, really common and I think it's even more common than people with a with a cancer diagnosis.
And so, yeah, your cholesterol is up, your LVL, C is up your HTL is stayed the same, which you love that to rise. It's not really rising that much.
Your triglycerides are up and that's really a side of inflammation.
Eating a lot more fats can be inflammatory. The other thing you want to look at too is your ability to break down fats. You want to look at your bile salts.
And the health of your gallbladder. So more questions really to ask like, how are you told you feel like you're digesting your fats to feel like you have to burp a lot after you eat.
Fat, eat more fatty foods, how your bowel movements change. Do you have stomach aches because of that? What is your HCL balance and you're got to be able to break down the proteins that you're eating.
Look at the blog I wrote about HCL and just alkalized or acidified your gut. So that's really important to follow that.
There's nothing wrong with getting a glyphosate test done.
Though again, this is like experience, probably going to be elevated. Additionally, regarding substitute sweet nurse, she believes that once that sweet taste hits the tongue, the brain registers that and sends the signals to the pancreas to do its thing.
Regardless of whether the sweeter is one that is metabolized or not. What do you think about that process? Yeah, I do know that that is a theory that.
The sweeter still affect a person because it's dealing with the brain and not so much with the chemistry of the metabolism of the product.
So, but if but understand the physiology there so if that what that can happen by eating times to sweet nurse, the danger that is you have an increase insulin production.
And that could actually cause hypoglycemia. So, I wouldn't cause hyperglycemia. So, what my curiosity abuse, what is your glucose level and how it is that you could test that by, you know, checking your blood glucose level.
So, if you have a glucometer at home, you could eat some substitute sweet nurse though. We're not talking about non natural substitute sweet nurse talking about like sugar alcohols, not like sucrose or something like that.
But, and then you're and then you're well or even stevia and see what it does to your blood sugar levels. Most likely it's not going to change your blood sugar levels.
So, you can look at that, but yeah, I do, you know, and there's like I said, there's people that have issues with sugar alcohols.
And I think too many sugar alcohols are not good either. That was a huge thing with atkins diet was really big. We had people come in and they might lose weight on the atkins diet, but they ended up with too many sugar alcohols.
So, there are alcohols because that's just pretty much what's the substitute of the day in the bars and things like that. And that could cause liver issues too.
A question came in. No problem with eating the fats, the CRP was very low like point one nine thought that that was a good indicator of information. Yeah, your C reactor protein is your one of your main indications of inflammation also.
Fairytid can be an indicator of inflammation in the blood too, but, but, as I can see our piece out going to be specific to anything, even though it's another test called HS CRP which is high sensitivity CRP, which says it's a little bit more accurate to vascular inflammation.
None of them are going to be specific to inflammation in the liver.
If you had a change in the fats with that change in diet, you still want to do some further investigation on your ability to digest those fats and your ability digest fats.
If you do have your pancreas does make my pace, which is an enzyme to digest fats, but the majority of fat digestion is from the bile. So the bile is made in the liver.
And it's created into the, via the bile duct into the gallbladder and then the bile gallbladder is created into the first part of swallow tested when it senses that there's fat there.
If a person has issues with the gallbladder, which is very, very common, more common in your female, then that could be part of the problem. You don't want to overlook that.
Next comment was also FYI. I didn't find any site that said all you lose was sugar alcohol. The one said it's not sugar alcohol, but chemical structure similar to fluke dose. Oh, that's interesting. Okay.
It could have a fluke dose sensitivity. That's another possibility too.
So that's, that's, it was, that's really good. I was used to work with 80, 80, 80, HD kids and spectrum kids, fluke dose sensitivity was a huge problem with them.
So it's because you have diagnosed cancer doesn't mean you don't have other core morbidities. So just got some blood test results back concerned about the alkaline phosphates and the AST.
They just keep going up. I have been on a new chemo pill for the last three weeks. I do a horrible blocker for four weeks. Not sure if all the work I have done the last month with these changes needs more time to work. What are your thoughts?
Yeah, I don't know the data on how fast these new, these new medications may work and how fast if they are working that it's going to change the alkaline phosphates.
Now, I understand alkaline phosphates and AST are, can indicate liver congestion.
Alkaline phosphates and but not AST. There's also an indicator of metastatic bony lytic destruction of both.
So, if the AST went up this time, it can be an indication and can tie with the alkaline phosphates can be an indication.
Just because what the chemo, how the chemo might be negatively affecting the liver and that's part of what you kind of have to go through what you're going to try and do chemo drug.
I would consider increasing your coffee enemas increasing doing castoral packs over the liver. That's what I would suggest to do with that.
Both alkaline phosphates and AST were elevated. I think that it can point to more of the liver issue than the bony issue.
So, I would increase things that are going to help flush the liver and get the liver flushed up, make sure you drink you plenty of water.
It's a really important thing for the summer months. We don't want to have you suffering from ill effects of dehydration and, you know, think it's, you know, and that could be a major thing and then you think it's something other than something as simple as dehydration.
Dehydration could be very serious, but it can be simple. It's a simple solution.
Is there a way to stimulate the salivary glands or otherwise addressed dry mouth after ahead of that radiation part of the reason I can't get back to swallow it normally because I have such a dry mouth.
Well, this is protic gland from biotics research. Now, I can't say that this is going to improve the function of the protic glands, but it would be something that you could consider.
Well, you have a decrease in the protic gland function, you, you want to build up the gland again, is that possible?
Well, it was damaged because of the radiation. So, when you damage other organs due to, you know, your cancer treatment, you've got to try to build that organ back up.
I would say give it a try. You have to call in to order this. You can't see it on our store site because this company doesn't allow online sales unless it's behind the curve.
My surgeon has suggested before by double mastectomy to get clips inserted into the suspicious lymph nodes, then during surgery, she'll make sure to remove those clips along with central lymph nodes to send to pathology.
She doesn't seem she doesn't like to rely on quick pathology done during surgery because she has gotten bad results before.
It's always nice to do it while you have the patient open another table, but if she's experienced, you know, bad results because the pathology report was wrong, then, you know, I think that's a good note she's being safer.
I'm sorry, so I think that's positive. After we see the results and whether those lip builds have cancer, then she do a second surgery or move eight to 15 more lip builds, she says this is conservative.
And I've asked for a microsurgery to reach hatch blood vessels to decrease chances of lymphedema, doesn't sound like a good reason to play.
Well, it sounds like she's being very thorough. I'd say it's a reasonable plan. Yes, that sounds good.
R2 is if there is cancer in the lymph node, she highly recommends radiation and says cancer has a 70% chance of returning it by don't.
I never like it with a person with a doctor throws a figure out like that because this is completely rubber numbers here.
So what do you mean if it's 70% chance of returning it? You actually keep those statistics. I don't think so.
So I have adhering to both you and Dr. Simmons that radiation is more destructive and curative.
So I have never said it's more destructive than church, but I am not a fan of soft tissue radiation, except for something like the prostate or something like that.
Doing radiation post surgery, they're doing kind of a blanket, big swat radiation, there's a lot of things to damage around your breasts, including blood vessels and very important for your heart.
So I'm not a big fan of doing radiation. I know it is standards of care to do love back to me plus radiation and chemotherapy if you're going to love back to me.
And then it's that standards of care used to be it might be changing now used to be if you do a mastectomy, then no radiation and chemotherapy.
And but if you're doing a lot back to me, you have to do radiation.
Just because that's what the pharmaceutical company put together does not mean it was right for you.
So, you know, get, you know, calls up for the multitude of people to make that decision.
Are there any studies I could show them?
I know I cite some studies in my book. I don't have the love top ahead, but I don't think sighted studies to your oncologists or your surgeon are going to help one bit.
But could actually hurt you because they could have some negative thoughts about you, you just got to say, you know, about comfortable with that.
Or all cross that bridge, but I get there.
And you could make a decision.
Understand sometimes people are suggesting things.
Because they're trying to cover with their tail. So from a.
From a point of view that from their point of view, they're, they have to make suggestions that their clinic group is telling them to make or they could be in trouble with their clinic group.
They could lose their job. They could lose their shirts. There's all sorts of things that they have to be careful.
So, even though maybe if they got cancer, they want to do that.
So, just continue to do your research with that.
If I start a round of Artemisidid, wood that health with bone, metastatic cancer from lymphoma, and what lines and how often.
So Artemisidid is an herb that is also called worm wood.
And these, but typically it's Artemisididodula, that is the herb that's used.
And it is can be good for cancer.
Most of the studies on Artemisidid have been for viral infections and a lot of studies for malaria.
So Artemisidid really told the story before, but it's just makes me mad and sad.
But Artemisididid is actually a wonderful killer of malaria.
And it actually is an herb. It's not, it grows like a shrub.
And it is, it is native to a lot of areas.
And one of the areas native to is Africa and understand it.
In Africa, it never would cause a death in Africa is malaria.
Well, there's a wonderful drug that the pharmaceutical companies have put out to take care of malaria.
So if you go over to Africa, you could take malaria medication with you and you won't die of malaria.
It's a wonderful drug. The problem is the cost of one dollar a day. Well, what's a big deal with dollar a day? That's nothing.
Well, to somebody in Africa dollar a day, they're literally, you know, the average person in a lot of countries in Africa may be making a dollar a day.
And they have four kids or 10 kids or something. They can't treat their whole family. So that's hence the leading cause of death in Africa.
Well, why don't they use Artemisidid? Well, truth is, about 15 years ago, the pharmaceutical companies systematically paid people to burn Artemisidid forests.
And they destroyed Artemisidid shrubs in the majority of Africa. That is a true story. That is sick sand and unbelievable, because they wanted to sell their drug.
So I know of two humanitarian groups that are their mission is to reproduce Artemisidid forests in Africa and they teach people how we use it.
Pretty cool.
But Artemisidid is a great thing for cancer, too. So it's not just for malaria, it can be really good for different viruses. It can be good for different infections, but it can also be really good for cancer.
This little slide that is shows what it does. It is decreases chronic inflammation and bad inflammation. It's a decrease or a bit or look in six, interleukin 1b, T and a falfa, and a capoveta.
And a capoveta is one of the very destructive inflammatory markers with cancer.
Interleukin 6 is a destructive inflammatory marker with bowl loss. So it would be, so in that sense, the question is, would Artemisidid be good for metastatic cancer?
Well, Artemisidid can be good for any cancer, but the only reason why I would say I haven't seen specific studies and say it's good for metastatic bone cancer in a sense, except that it decreases interleukin 6.
This one right here, IL-6, interleukin 6 is highly elevated, whatever there's bone loss. So not just with metastatic cancer to the bone, but also with osteoporosis. So osteoporosis is an inflammatory disease because you have a lack of calcium.
So it's because you have an inflammatory disorder to the bones with a highly elevated interleukin 6.
Now, there is one thing that is better than Artemisidid to decrease interleukin 6, and it's EGCG from green T-extric.
So the T-vego product from US enzymes would do even a better job than Artemisidid to decrease interleukin 6 at the bone.
But you can certainly feel that to take Artemisidid can be good for cancer in general.
So, you know, it's a great product to take. Now, understand, why don't you recommend that to everybody? Well, there's tons of great products to take, and I think, you know, I don't want everybody to be on an overload of products that they're taking.
The Artemisidid that I would say to use, I'm going to find it here, I'll pull it up and show it to you.
Is this one right here called Artemisidid Solo by Research Nutritionals, and I would take two to three of these a day.
This I think is the better, the best Artemisidid on the market right now.
And I've been using Artemisidid for decades because Artemisid not personally, I don't take Artemisidid currently, but I've been using it a lot with Lyme disease because it's one of the great, you know, hidden Lyme disease killer.
So Artemisid can be a real benefit of that.
But it can be another thing you can use for cancer, I have, you know, in the Shakespeare test, I have a number of people that might even be on this call that are taking that I recommend for the missing.
But it can be something that anybody can add.
So, can you take the Artemisidid with TV? Oh, yes, yep, yep. We're going a little bit different pathways, but they both do decrease that internal six.
My AFP is still elevated still in the 10 to 14 range when it should be below six any thoughts on why none of my doctors know why is it possible that 10 to 14 is by normal range.
So this person has had surgery, AFP is a trigger marker.
And they're wondering why debugging the cancer did it decreased a lot of things, but not their AMP.
So why does a tumor marker not go down when you debug the cancer, there may even be no evidence of disease anywhere, but the tumor marker is still elevated.
So remember, these are different proteins that are in the blood.
So does it, it doesn't always mean if you have an elevated tumor marker that you have, you have some sort of cancer, the answers, no.
So, the matter of fact, there is a normal range. So AFP normal range should be below six. That means five would be within normal range in a person could not have cancer and still have five because it's not just made these things are not just made by tumors.
And there may be an up regulation on other cells that are making these proteins after post cancer.
So it could be a neurological up regulation of other cells that are making this this protein.
And it's not just AFP, any of the tumor markers. So two markers are just, it's remembered like any test, it's just one test that is a possible indicator of something going on. So you weigh that test out with comparing with other tests and other signs and symptoms.
So different objective tests and different subjective signs and symptoms, you weigh that all out. Could your range just be normally high? Well, it could, how would we know that? Well, there's no way we could, unless we could, you know, jump at our time machine and go back to precancer days and run an app and see if it is elevated then.
But even that it could literally have been what I first described that because you had cancer, you have an up regulation of production of AMP of other cells too. So you're just making more of it.
Could it be that I am hidden cancer somewhere that's not fun could be that you still know you want to do other tests. You don't rely on just one test. You don't, you know, you just don't, you just look at other signs and symptoms.
You could have something that's that's that's that's that's increasing that has nothing to do with kids.
When I sent my cheek swab, you suggested a few additions and increased a couple of the supplements you recommend. Does that mean I stay on all the others. Yes.
So I'm just giving you the changes in that cheek swab test. Yes. I don't know if you evaluated everything on the spreadsheet that I sent. Yes, I did.
Including those from another practitioner. Yes, that's best I could I didn't have I don't have all those so I don't know if I did as best as I could other questions.
What is an agotite score. So an agotite score score is a test that's done by your oncologist to see how you
would see a chemo would be a good fit for you. So that's that's what an agotite score is.
So the test you against chemo and old chemo would really work well for you based upon I think it's a genetic factor that they look at and they see if that would work well for you.
I think to I think of bedbed. So bedbed is all is a dewormer.
And bedbed is all is the name of the you were were given to animals.
We have a number of people on bedbed is on are there downsides of bedbed is all using bed that bed is on.
Well, it is a drug. Are there downsides to it? Maybe. Have I ever seen any downsides to it? No, I've had a couple of people say it gave him the stomachache, but I don't know if it was that bedbed is all they gave him the stomachache.
I think that was more in their hand they thought never scared because they don't ever take drugs when they took it, they thought they had a stomachache.
You can take it with food. You shouldn't get a stomachache with it. You're really taking as much as you would give a 10 pound dog.
So if you weigh 130, 180 pounds, you're taking such a low dose of it. You really should not have any side effects of it.
Is it going to deworm your body? Is it going to affect your microbiota? There's no there's no studies that I've seen that it damages your microbiota.
And at that dose, you probably not going to do a whole lot of deworming of you anyhow.
It's a totally different mechanism that's happening with bed is on cancer.
And we have seen it help a lot of people. We have a lot of people taking bed is on.
A number of you on this call maybe on bed is on. It can be a great thing to and to your protocol.
How often should I get a pet scan now?
What's the best way to check for reoccurrence?
Well, I think the best way to check for reoccurrence is probably a pet scan.
And that would be the gold standard. The negatin of that, it's about two and a half times the radiation dose of a CT scan.
You do get a lot of radiation from a pet scan. So you don't want to do it very often.
It partly depends on the person I personally haven't had a scandal for.
I think it was two years ago that I did my scan. I think it was two years in March that I did my scan.
And it was good except for some liver lesions.
And if I go to do another scan probably not so that's just me. So that's just my choice.
So everybody's different. Everybody has different levels of anxiety. Everybody has different levels of what they're going to do.
A standards of care approach because because of our makeup because of who we are.
And because of our cancer with me.
It's an easy decision for me because there is nothing that standards of care offers for my cancer.
So I mean, statistically, I should have been dead a couple years ago.
So, you know, statistically, it's a seven percent five year survival rate.
You know, I've had six and a half years now, I think.
So it's, it's.
I'm not going to do another scan. You know, even if my symptoms get really bad. I'm from, I'm still not going to do another scan because nothing they can do for me.
So, but you know, you have other options with press cancer. So maybe you would do it other scan.
And you might have different levels of, you know, anxiety that you're struggling with with things and to get another scan can be helpful to relieve that anxiety.
So, you, is there damage that could occur?
Because of the radiation of the scan. Sure. But you just got to weigh out what, you know, what's better for you emotionally to know that you're doing well or.
And deal with the radiation and detox that and support your body through that or to, to not. So you've, you've got to weigh that out.
So it would be okay to take the Artemis and solo with the TV go from Mr. Absolutely up. You can take those together. There's really no.
Honestly, but you're not, you're not taking it excess of stuff. So you're fine. You know, but there's, you know, there's some people that aren't taking, you know, 100 different bottles of supplements not for my recommendation, but they're taking a ton of stuff because they're going to multiple practitioners and adding another thing is probably not why so you don't get into that category.
What is a great, I see that mentioned by women in a Facebook group. Nobody has ever given me my grade. So there's, you could Google search ways that they measure severity of different cancers. They've changed the way that they measure breast cancer in the last five years.
So, and if but not all oncologists use those measurements. So you could Google the different ways that you measure the severity of different cancers.
I think I might have written a blog post about it.
A while back when I can't remember. Maybe it's in my book. I can't remember because we don't go that so my questions said yesterday.
Did you send questions via the so if you have questions that you send in then make sure that you send them on the member site.
I told all the questions on the member site. So maybe send those again and we'll get to those next week if you can't think about type of another.
Is Ben Benzino the same as Fen Ben yes, but it's the human drug for that.
If therapy affect the stent in my kidney and your nose, not at all. So the frequencies. So if you were to an electrical frequencies, you could have a fact of the stent, but not my frequencies.
Electrical frequencies, you're like doing the peak, you're doing a peak in that. You have to be careful with stents.
Well, partly because it depends on how much period after you're doing a daily basis. And you certainly have to be careful if you had a pacemaker.
You really shouldn't repeat that at all in a pacemaker. But to write, there's no contraindications for any mental implants.
And when I did mention mental implants before about chelation, stainless steel, stent is not considered a contraindication for chelation.
Is it okay to use right frequency for parasites and can need a daily or two to three times a week. Sure, you can do it every single day.
If you're running, if you don't have parasites and you're running parasite, it's not going to do anything.
But if you have parasites, you're going to kill parasites. Now the parasite frequencies and the candida frequencies.
You know, could you kill too fast and cause issues? Not really. Where you could kill too fast and cause issues using the right machine is if you're killing a gram negative bacteria.
So what would gram negative bacteria be? Well, mainly the most common is Lyme disease, merglidorphine, the gram negative bacteria for Lyme disease.
Why is that bad? Is gram negative bacteria have lipopolysaccharides in the cell and their cell wall? And when you kill a gram negative bacteria, you liberate lipopolysaccharides and lipopolysaccharides, stimulated immune function.
It abudes a stimulation. And if you already have a photo immune issues, which many Lyme patients have, they get what's called a herc cyber reaction and they get you're really sick. So that's the only negatives about using the right zip you have Lyme, you don't want to try to kill too quickly.
There isn't, you know, you're running, you know, any other frequencies like that are non Lyme programs. You're going to be just fine.
My oncologist said that my cancer could also change from hormone positive negative, trying to get me to do a biopsy again. I would totally agree with you. Matter of fact, I can't tell you how many people, how many women that will start with us and they have grant, they have hormone negative. So they have triple negative breast cancer.
And then we test that just in our cheek. So I'm testing that they do well with a dim or something like that. So I don't believe all those pathology reports personally.
So regardless of whether your cancer switches to hormone negative or hormone positive, that would just be, I think your oncologist is just concerned that they want to switch therapy. So they want to do change a drug.
So if you're on a drug slash chemotherapy with the oncologist, that's based upon you be grand positive or grand negative, then, then, you know, maybe testing is in order for them.
We've had patients too with multiple breast lesions and biopsy different breast lesions and one comes back or positive when one comes back or no negative.
So I don't always trust those pathology reports, but if you're not doing, you know, if you're not currently doing chemo, you don't plan on doing chemo, you're not doing any medication, what is it making difference to them, whether you're horrible positive or negative. So I think that would be my concern.
How legitimate are meridians and chakras physically and spiritually.
So meridians are just energy pathways that are used by acupuncturists. So an acupuncturist is looking at different acupuncture points that are along a meridian.
Now, that's different than a chakra. So meridians are energy points on our acupuncturists are on different radians that are that are energy pathways.
Now, it used to be I used to have to say about 25 years ago that they're not measurable, but they are measurable now. You can actually measure those energy pathways.
That is very physical and there's nothing spiritual about them. So acupuncture is not a spiritual technique. It's not a religious technique. And there's no reason for Christians to not do acupuncture for the spiritual standpoint.
Now, it might be a reason to not go to an acupuncturist that's a Buddhist or something like that. But you don't, but the practice of acupuncture itself is not a spiritual practice.
Chakras are a little controversial because that is a little bit different.
And that can be very spiritual. So I don't like to talk about chakras myself. So I don't discuss chakras. And I did that is not measurable.
Now, what would say, oh, you could measure energy on the chakra. Well, that's really just that specific meridian. So, so I don't buy into the chakra thing. I think it's used by new ages and I'm not into that.
And I think that could be dangerous from a spiritual perspective. I do believe that as a believer, you could be protected from all of that. And you don't have to worry about those things. But I do think we're supposed to use wisdom and I'll put ourselves up to
practice occultic practice. So I would stay right from that.
Have you ever used advanced TRS 100% data, zero light for heavy metal? Yes. So we have multiple products with zero light in them, which could be extremely beneficial.
It is a key later. Now, understand zero light is really well absorbed. So a lot of people classify zero light as a binder.
But, you know, how much you take you are absorbing some zero light in it can be a good, it can be a good key layer. So it's there. It's a good product. We have number of products with zero light in it.
So with all the turmeric and mousse, I own, et cetera, that I'm taking I'm still getting the inflammatory side effects of the hormone blockers in the drug.
Most notably there, it's really feeling to my hands and wrists.
It's hand input syndrome. I guess I have to just deal with it for now.
The clear talks, provide clear and adaptive clear, you recommend help. So the clear talks will help with that. The probiotic, no, the adaptive clear, no.
The probiotic, that's a, that's a gut brain probiotic to do what I'm really excited about the adapt clear is an adapt agent.
But the problem with using, you know, you're trying to detox your body. At the same time as your toxifying your body, it's a battle. It's a, it's a, it's a tug of war that you're dealing with. So you just got to keep doing as many things as you possibly can to keep yourself.
It's been maybe 18 months since the last cheek swap for me. That's a long time. So probably should probably not wait for about six months, but you do well.
I was ready to send one in when the medical police said you couldn't do them anymore. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Well, we don't have medical police are back for that right now. Oh, by the way, the reason why the video for the last week's Zoom call, what had to be put up as a video on our member site is because the video police were after us.
So, um, funny. It's just it's hilarious. So it's hilarious and in depression at the same time. So we got a awarding our first strike from YouTube, three strikes, they take your whole channel down. So we might lose our whole channel.
Um, same thing that Rekola guy. Why? Because we posted something about cancer. Well, their AI hasn't picked up all our other videos on cancer. The one that they picked up was hydrogen peroxide for cancer, not so fast.
It actually says you shouldn't take hydrogen peroxide for cancer.
Oh, my gosh. So again, it's not a person that's actually looking for this. They just have AI's, you know, scrubby the internet and we got a strike. So I couldn't post anything on our YouTube channel for one week. That was the penalty that I got. I was in YouTube jail for one week.
So we had to put it up that way. So we're looking at different ways to get, you know, the videos up there. The benefit of YouTube is that they have that player, that YouTube player so that I can put it into that category and you can watch all the videos that are our Zoom call videos and we can't find another video company that has that same thing.
So, uh, frustrating. So yeah, we got docked our strike one from YouTube because we had a video on cancer.
So yes, we do retested. We could retest for almost things. We can start from scratch and retest everything. I do want you to send in the form on the member site that goes along with cheeks one, please.
Okay, I am terrible insomnia. I started it started when I went on antibiotics for staff. I have not slept more than four hours and a 24 hour period usually.
Like one to two hours.
In the last month, it takes forever to get to sleep.
Okay, so you might be experiencing some what's called pain or kindness, which is not uncommon after a strap or strap staff infection because it can affect your brain.
You could cross the blood and brain barrier.
Look at my video on brain inflammation. If you search the blog brain inflammation that will help is that what that can do is it could cause microglial priming damages to microglial cells.
And you have that inflammation in the brain.
So there's, and I give in that video and what to do for that. It's really just hide us.
I miss most of the soon call. It will be posted as soon as I possibly can. Lava Quinn gives me the sun.
So if you look at the blog about and search for information.
All right, with that, we'll be to do for the day. Thank you all know that I prayed for all of you and I'll get this video up.
If I can't post to YouTube, I haven't tried the last couple of days. I think we're all on YouTube jail.
I'll post to YouTube. I'll get it up other members. I just.
All right. Love you all. I prayed for you. And we'll see you next week.